dont pierre combet l'expert aéronautique
bonsoir jean pierre combelles merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
le chiffre donne vraiment le vertige
réduction des vols jusqu'à 95% parfois
comment air france
et hop notamment avec transavia peuvent
résister survivre à cette période
extrêmement compliqué la situation est
difficile pour eux puisque quand les
passagers ne vole plus les recettes ne
rentre plus dans la compagnie par contre
les charges fixes les loyers d'avion qui
se compte en centaines de milliards
centaines de milliers de dollars par
mois et par avion 50 il eu à courir les
assurances des avions au sol peuvent
être un peu négocier à la baisse si les
avions sur le sol les primes vont
diminuer mais les marges
un pourcentage de chiffre d'affaires de
compagnie aérienne ces quelques
pourcents c'est pas beaucoup plus donc
quand les recettes diminuent la
compagnie immédiatement en danger on
peut se poser la question effectivement
on sait que le transport aérien déjà
connu des turbulences c'est le cas de le
dire mais à ce point est ce qu'il ya eu
des précédents
j'ai travaillé je suis à la retraite
aujourd'hui je suis expert judiciaire
mais j'ai travaillé 50 ans dans
l'aviation j'ai jamais vu ça mais bon je
me dis aussi que cette cette période de
coronavirus ça va durer deux mois disons
trois mois maximum je pense en voilà la
chine diminué
donc je pense que les compagnies qui
restent debout vont négocier le retard
demande deux à trois mois de leurs de
leurs loyers ont reculé à la dernière
échéance
et puis notre pays il a passé j'ai mes
grands parents qui ont passé la première
guerre mondiale mais par an passé la
deuxième
la france va se relever ça me paraît
évident alors il ya un sujet un gros
changement de stratégie du gouvernement
comme quoi parfois la réalité et le
pragmatisme l'emportent gérald darmanin
qui a évoqué une nationalisation en
l'occurrence une renationalisation reno
lemaire tempère aujourd'hui qu'on fera
rien sans l'accord évidemment des pays
bas il ya cette alliance avec klm qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous en tant que
experts quand vous entends par là que
vous entendez parler de nationalisation
je pense d'abord que le pays
100% de paix de pib de dette
le pays peut pas faire n'importe quoi et
j'ai en tête une phrase de churchill qui
disait tout l'argent car vous donne
l'heure où le prend par l'autre poche
alors moi je pense qu'il faut être
extrêmement prudent quand on parle de
nationalisation je suis personnellement
convaincu qu'ils adorent pas merci en
tout cas jean pierre combes elle d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci à vous